Venna Adil's burger would give anything
for this sound
in fact he spent over a hundred thousand
euros on his horn loudspeakers as enough
I didn't you have to differentiate
between listening to music you can do
that with any system and experiencing
music that typical feeling you get it
live concerts you get that pretty much
only with horns the way they draw in the
listener is amazing you get what I call
the goosepimple
effect guns elope pin sound effect the
loudspeakers are made by a company based
in the odontoid region in the state of
Hessen about 20 people work here systems
from avant-garde acoustic end up in
people's homes or on luxury yachts their
high-end handmade goods for connoisseurs
the heart of the system is the horn
these funnels amplify the sound the way
the horns on gramophones used to hold of
homer expanded on the old principle
sound is reproduced in a loudspeaker
using a membrane that oscillates in time
with the music
the bigger the membrane the heavier it
is and they're less able to follow the
natural patterns of the music that's why
we use the horn principle technology
based on the human ear avant-garde
acoustic is a flourishing business with
customers worldwide
it all began 25 years ago I was lucky
enough to hear a horn loudspeaker at a
rock concert once I was so fascinated
then I got hold of some literature
through East Germany that took over a
year then I calculated my own horns and
made them in my mother's garden using
plaster molds I got so caught up in it
that in the end my hobby became my
profession mine hobbits evolved come
October the horns are only part of the
speaker's
everything is precisely assembled and
tested to ensure the sound is just right
when customers switch on their systems
this is vie bohème for alliance it's
like familiar one they also drive manual
cars not automatics because they're
faster we need to ensure optimal
settings to give optimum performance
holograph commoners backyard enterprise
has become a very successful company in
fact it's booming even the smallest horn
costs fifteen thousand euros the model
is very popular in Asia thank you now
regional differences of course this
model for example was designed
especially for the Japanese market it's
smaller so it's easier to integrate into
those apartments Holga formas largest
model is on display in the showroom it's
not cheap but farmer says nothing can
beat it except a live concert